hey milkshakers
welcome to the show it's me your host
rayne wilson and with me today
is his co-host cyrus
my wait wait who who's there who is that
cyrus
cyrus aslan reza aslan's son
why are you where's your dad
well you know what no you know what do
what cyrus just stay stay there stay put
stay by the microphone since i have you
today's episode um
is all about having adventures in
philosophy with kids
you're a kid have you ever thought about
philosophy
um
i don't know
i think that's a good answer
um tell me about it
what what
are you doing my podcasting
duties wait wait i've got a question for
cyrus this is this is a podcast for big
ideas there's no room for kids here
welcome to metaphysical milkshake the
show where we go deep we get weird and
we search for the meaning of life along
the way presented by cast media and soul
pancake
[Music]
well reza that was uh that was strangely
appropriate how did that ever happen
you know cyrus he gets into things he
gets into podcasts apparently you can't
give a kid a microphone because as as
everyone knows kids say the darndest
things and they often say the darndest
philosophical things i'm very transition
yeah how about that
uh for today's episode a terrific book
folks scott hershevitz wrote a book
called nasty brutish and short
adventures in philosophy with my kids
um and how much we can learn about
philosophy by having conversations
around philosophy with children there's
much more to it than that but a really
exciting uh book
uh do your kids uh
sometimes present you with philosophical
quandaries russell yes all the time
like
should i stop having them
[Laughter]
folks we're gonna have a scintillating
conversation but let me tell you a
little bit more about scott hirschevitz
he's a professor of law and philosophy
at the university of michigan he directs
their law and ethics program and he's
editor of journal of legal theory
he writes about philosophy he even wrote
about the philosophy of taylor swift
for the new york times
prior to joining the faculty at michigan
he served as a law clerk to justice ruth
bader ginsburg
and was an attorney advisor on the
appellate staff of the civil division of
the us department of justice
he's got undergraduate and graduate
degrees in political science philosophy
he's got a doctorate in legal philosophy
from oxford where he was a rhodes
scholar
he's got a book about jurisprudence
called law is a moral practice
and he is fascinated by the
philosophical questions related
to
law and he is now an author of a book
for adults and kids and adults with kids
nasty brutish and short adventures
in philosophy with my kids let's welcome
to the show scott hershevitz
thank you so much for having me it's
super excited to be here the book again
is nasty brutish and short adventures in
philosophy with my kids it's such a
delightful book you know it's funny i
was um talking to my kids during dinner
last night and they were like well what
what is uh a philosopher and i was like
well you know philosophy is the the love
of wisdom the love of knowledge and a
philosopher is somebody who you know
like
thinks big thoughts and and asks uh big
unanswerable questions and they're like
that's not a job
that's not that's not a real job
no no no it's an actual
paid
job that people
have
they wouldn't believe me they still
don't they still don't believe me
you know i'm not sure that i believe it
either and i have the job so you know
when i'm out in the world and people ask
me what i do i've never once told a
stranger that i'm a philosopher because
it doesn't sound like a thing it's not
real right so
um i'm also a lawyer so i i usually lead
with usually lead with that
um but my my father also had just like
the same concern when i went home and
said like i think i want to major in
philosophy is
what's what's philosophy and i had i i
was in a philosophy class i decided this
is what i wanted to do with my life and
i couldn't explain it either uh so it's
a hard thing to explain but my kid
actually helped me understand uh when i
was when he was in second grade the
teacher on the first day of school said
what do you want to be when you grow up
and he said he wanted to be a
philosopher of math or is he put a math
philosopher and so i said to him what's
a philosopher and just instantly he said
philosophy is the art of thinking
so
that's what that's what i'm going with
philosophy is the art of thinking is
that is that how you would describe like
to a kid like if a kid asked you what do
you do
so when i when my kids were little and i
was trying to explain to them my job i
would tell them that philosophers are
people who think of really good
questions
and then try to think of answers
and
uh you know and that's not fully
adequate because you know they would be
like oh like um
uh you know
here's a question like
where did i leave where did i leave my
favorite stuffed animal and i'd be like
well that's a good question
but that's not that's not exactly what
we're after it's a kind of you know it's
like you want to distinguish like the
things that we can investigate
empirically from the things that we can
only investigate by thinking them
through that's that's the target of
philosophy so i have a question
i uh took some philosophy courses in
college which i greatly enjoyed but it
seemed to me
very clear that there were two kinds of
philosophers there were namely the
academic philosopher that
stayed in school and stayed purely in
the academic realm
kind of began with words and ended with
words
zero kind of social or psychological
relevance to the conversations
it seemed to me
but then there's this whole other school
of um in an ancient school of kind of
social philosophers you know who
talk about these big ideas in the public
square i'm thinking about uh allendu
baton of course socrates the first one
zizek whatever that guy is slavosh zizek
yeah
cornell west
noam chomsky etc
um
now what kind of philosopher
are you
so i think of myself as somebody who's
straddling the border between these two
worlds and that may be because i'm a
philosopher of law i teach primarily in
a law school i talk to my students about
philosophical questions about law are we
obligated to obey the law what is civil
disobedience how is it different from
other forms of law breaking and so
i you know the kinds of questions i have
in my academic work are really questions
that are
engaged in the world
and practically relevant to decisions
that individuals and institutions have
to make but i actually think like
there's like a really exciting
transformation happening in academic
philosophy generally i think a lot of
philosophers are um watching the the
world seem to burn around them and
they're uh they're asking you know what
is it what what do the tool what do the
tools we have
offer the world and so like for instance
you mentioned words and philosophy of
language there is a kind of growing
movie called growing movement called the
social and political philosophy of
language that um is asking like
questions like what are slurs and why
are slurs bad or what's propaganda and
how does it work just how does like
the um
you know jason stanley at yale has done
really terrific uh work trying to
understand um like the ways in which
words are used
to manipulate us
see this is important because
i don't have to tell you this but you
know philosophers they get a bad rap uh
i think you know a lot of especially you
get this from scientists a lot right uh
you know like what is the point uh we
were we were doing some research on the
way that you know some sort of more of
these popular pop scientists
uh have thought about philosophy and uh
this is you know quote by neil degrasse
tyson
who from what i understand never shuts
the [ __ ] up right i mean this guy
has an opinion
has an opinion on every [ __ ] thing
right i mean isn't that isn't that but
reza isn't that like jordan peterson too
oh jesus christ there's actually some
things i think jordan peterson says that
are pretty wise but then you'll you'll
ask his opinion about
i don't know north korea and he'll just
go on for like days yes uh or you know
or
women's vaginas and he'll lecture you in
the history of he'll mansplain women's
vaginas to you
you know he's got this whole thing where
he's like
uh you know why are you concerning
yourself with the meaning of meaning if
you are distracted by your question so
that you can't move forward you are not
being a productive contributor to our
understanding of the natural world and
so the scientist knows when the question
what is the sound of one hand clapping
is a pointless delay in our progress now
let's put aside the utterly facile
conception
of philosophy and what a philosopher
does from a so-called scientist um you
know how do you hold on a second because
i also want to say and i'm sorry i keep
interrupting reza what is the sound of
one hand clapping is a zen koan yeah
it's not it's not a
question it is there
it is there to help you perceive the
world in a slightly different way and uh
anyway continue sorry
the title of this episode of the podcast
is why won't neil degrasse tyson shut
the [ __ ] up but
uh
you know what like i mean what do you
say to that kind of of criticism about
philosophy
so
you know most of the sciences were
actually all the scientists were in a
way born out of philosophy um and
philosophy sort of hands questions over
when it turns out that other disciplines
have developed tools for addressing them
better than we can just by thinking them
through and it's actually a really
wonderful thing when we develop tools
for addressing different kinds of
questions so i give an example in the
book i offer um an argument that my uh
my older son rex made when he was seven
years old he just said to me just to go
into neil degrasse tyson's space we were
walking home from school one day and he
said to me
you know the universe is infinite and i
was like i don't know buddy i think
scientists disagree about that some
think it's infinite some people think
it's really big but it's finite and he's
like no it has to be infinite
why so he made me an argument the
argument's clever he says like suppose
you take a spaceship all the way to the
end of the universe and then you're just
you're right there and you punch your
hand he looks at me he says it has to go
somewhere right i said i know what if it
just stops he says well if it stops then
something's stopping it so you weren't
at the end yet
and you know i knew i knew like enough
physics to know like this is not a great
argument because it turns out you can
have finite spaces without edges so like
think about the surface of a balloon
like if you're an ant walking on the
surface of a balloon you can walk
forever and you're never going to hit an
edge because the space folds back on
itself so it's finite but it doesn't
have edges some people think the
universe might work some scientists
think the universe might work like that
but i was describing this um i was
describing this argument that my kid rex
had made to a philosopher of physics and
he's like oh yeah that that people make
that argument for thousands of years
like the first recorded version of it is
this guy named architoss
right um
and uh and you know people were trying
just with the tools that they had which
was the power of their own mind to
understand what the universe is like
well now we have other tools right neil
degrasse tyson right can go to his
observatory and he can use his powerful
telescopes and they can look into the
past and they can do all kinds of um
you know experiments to try and
understand the way space is structured
this is going to be a better way of
getting at the question than just trying
to reason it through with your own mind
but there are questions that we've got
really important questions where we
don't have better tools yet and we may
never so if you want to know what
justice is or what beauty is or just how
you should be in the world like what's
the best way to live
um you know we
some of this may be you know we can try
things out and see how they go but a lot
of these questions say what's justice or
what's truth these are questions that we
have to
to answer by thinking them through
that's brilliant that reminds me that
conversation with your son reminds me
the end of the of the truman show it's
really one of my favorite movies and it
really holds up and the the ending is
one of the best endings ever but when he
he sails the boat
bumps into the side of his universe and
there's a little stairway with a door
and then there's a whole other reality
beyond the reality that he thought was
reality um
it's uh it's both
it echoes with science and philosophy
and spirituality that that ending
you know sometimes fun gets pushed to
the very bottom of our priority list
we're always waiting for that free time
to do something
fun and exciting that uplifts us
how often do you let yourself have some
harder and fun
you deserve more fun you deserve maximum
fun okay some joy to your daily routine
try the new game best fiends it's a
puzzle adventure game you won't be able
to put down
i am currently on level 19. i really
can't get enough of this
it's hard to describe you get these
little characters these little guys
they're your friends i just got this new
one named tantrum the dung beetle
and um
you line up various
leaves and you're shooting powers at the
evil slugs and you're collecting
treasure along the way
it's super fun to just pick up and play
at any time you can get a level done
just like that best fiends is a free to
download mobile puzzle game with
thousands of exciting levels for new
adventures and challenges every single
time you play there are dozens of unique
fiends to collect so you can customize
your team of fiends to defeat the
menacing slugs power up your favorite
fiends to get new levels from even more
powerful skills and watch them transform
as they get stronger and with offline
play you'll never be stranded for fun
even if you lose your internet
connection there's brand new events and
challenges that pop up all year round
you've always got a chance to earn
exclusive in-game items
characters
and rewards ladies and gentlemen you've
earned some fun time it's been a rough
couple years go to the app store or
google play to download best fiends
for free plus earn even more with five
dollars worth of in-game rewards when
you reach level five that's friends
without the r
best
fiends
milkshakers public goods is the one-stop
shop for sustainable high-quality
everyday essentials made from clean
ingredients at an affordable price
everything from personal care and
household products to coffee toilet
paper shampoo pet food and more public
goods is your new everything store
thoughtfully designed for the conscious
consumer rather than buying from a bunch
of single product brands public goods
members can buy all of their premium
essentials in one place with the
beautiful
streamlined aesthetic they have these
refillable bottles uh they're very
aesthetically pleasing and i keep it
stocked up
right outside of my office as a matter
of fact
so knowing what's in your products and
where they come from is important they
ethically source and obsessively develop
each of their products to be free of
unhealthy ingredients and harmful
additives still common on drug and
grocery store shelves they are committed
to making their products healthy and
safe for humans animals and the
environment they use a membership model
to keep costs low and pass on even more
savings to their customers best of all
you can make your first purchase with no
obligation so join hundreds of thousands
of others who have switched over to
their new
everything store public goods
and we have worked out an awesome deal
receive fifteen 15
off of your first public goods order
with no minimum purchase that's right
they are so confident that you're
absolutely going to love their products
and that you're going to come back again
and again that they're giving you 15
to spend on your first purchase
you got nothing to lose here's what you
do go to publicgoods.commilkshake
or use the code milkshake at checkout
that is p u b l i c g o o d s dot com
forward slash milkshake to receive 15
off your first order at public goods
thank you so much
my son is in high school uh here in
california and
one of the things we found really odd
about his education is uh
they don't even offer creative writing
there's not even an option to take a
creative writing class
and in none of his english classes to
date has he done any creative writing
all english
has turned into just analysis of books
and stories and outlines for essays
which is
i guess it's good for testing and maybe
it's good for getting you into you know
the uc schools or something like that
but this whole aspect of language of
like inventing stories
like they just simply don't teach
anymore it's it's not there and this has
kind of happened nationwide
with philosophy
in the schools you know it it uh you
know it used to be part of high school
curriculums i took great books in high
school and i'm so grateful because i was
reading
kant and nietzsche and and rousseau and
um
and side by side with literature as well
we've talked about this before
on the show but i think we're we're kind
of lacking i know in france they have a
very strong system for teaching
philosophy to teenagers
and
perhaps
there is contained in philosophy some of
the most vital skills for the modern age
critical thinking
tolerance for opposing viewpoints right
when you're in a philosophical debate
you're not just outraged immediately if
someone has a different point of view on
reality than you have but um what do you
think about uh philosophy and and it's
uh
it's woeful
lack of any kind of presence in the
american educational system
you went to a better high school than i
did i didn't encounter philosophy until
i was in college and it was only by
accident that i encountered it i wanted
to take a psychology class and it was
full and well here we are today i
thought maybe you just misspelled it
yeah i know i bubbled in the form
drawing back when we bubbled in bubbled
in forms however i ended up in that
class you know i do wonder what would
have happened if i'd been in the other
one but you know i do think the rest of
the world is ahead of us um we're lost
to the rest of the world ahead of us on
including philosophy as a part of basic
education i actually think it should be
part of education
well before
high school um so
uh you know i have visited my kids class
and sometimes i'll take picture books
and
uh you know actually the parental
institute for ethics has this website
called teaching children philosophy if
you just google teaching children
philosophy it has these modules for
lots of picture books the most common
ones books people own anyway so like
knuffle bunny or
um
or um frederick it's just like an
endless series of like the classic
picture books and it provides a little
primer for parents here's some
philosophical questions that come up in
this story and here are like discussion
questions you might ask your kids
as you read and kids really love
engaging these questions and they really
love thinking deeply they just pour
themselves into the conversation and i
think that you you can really help them
develop two skills one is like to hold
on to this desire to think deeply about
things and then the second is if you do
it in a group if you do it in a
classroom and you set some norms around
the engagement of we're gonna take turns
listening to each other and we're going
to disagree but we're going to disagree
respectfully and we're going to try to
understand what the other person is
saying then i think you could cultivate
sort of better habits of
discourse and exchange and argument than
we have in our culture generally yeah i
think this would come as a shock to a
lot of americans that most
other countries
in the world most of europe most of
latin america
uh actually require
some form of philosophy education at the
high school level uh obviously we do not
in the us and
i think more importantly studies
routinely show that kids who study
philosophy have higher test scores on on
verbal
uh their verbal skills on computational
intelligence than those who do not which
you know goes a long way to explaining
why uh you know our high school kids are
just so much dumber than
uh other high school kids but
you you say that you have this line in
the book uh that
um
that
all kids
all kids without exception
are philosophers right um
what do you mean by that what makes kids
such great philosophers
so
kids are really phenomenal philosophers
because for two reasons i think one is
they've just been dropped into the world
and there's lots that's confusing about
it and they're constantly puzzled and
they're trying to put it together and
they don't yet know
what the standard explanations of things
are and they don't yet know what
questions adults don't think are worth
asking they haven't listened to neil
degrasse tyson's endless explanations of
things or his dismissals of things that
he doesn't understand uh and so
they're they're just quizzical um and
creative and they see possibilities that
adults don't and they challenge things
that adults
take for granted so i think that's the
first reason the second reason is
uh they're not afraid of seeming silly
right silly is the business that they're
in
and they're not worried about being
wrong they're wrong all the time and so
they just try ideas out
and um
and you know like so i i think like you
know the story about rex and his
argument about the universe i think is
revealing at seven he was just putting
it out there i figured out that the
universe goes on forever let me tell you
why if he'd thought of that argument
when he was 17
i'm not sure that he would have been so
quick to share it um and to like put it
out as a topic of conversation so i
think those are the like the two
advantages kids have over a lot of
adults is
they um
they're they're puzzled and trying to
make sense of things and they're they're
fearless because they're not really
worried about what other people think
yeah john benville has this uh this
great line about childhood he says
childhood is quote a state of constantly
recurring astonishment
and
i mean what better
you know playground for philosophical
thinking i love i love hearing that
because it makes me realize reza like
i'm in a i'm in a constant state of like
anxiety despair and eye roll
and occasional outrage but when about
when's the last time i've been
astonished i started something yeah
there was a lunar eclipse a couple weeks
ago
and i was pretty astonished at the
the color of the moon it was just
something that i had never seen before
but it's it's pretty darn rare that i'm
astonished yeah you know i was having
lunch with another philosopher last week
and he was telling me that he started
taking his five-year-old daughter out to
restaurants and she'd been to
restaurants before the pandemic but
she'd just forgotten
what it was like and she was having this
experience of astonishment just that you
could be someplace else and people would
bring you food you could ask for what
you wanted to come to your table and
that's just like the perpetual state of
of these people is like everything is
new and they're full of you know one of
my favorite stories just to give you an
illustration one of my favorite stories
in the book comes from this philosopher
gareth matthews who
dedicated his career to kids and you
know gathered stories from parents went
to schools talked to kids and
he
was talking to a mother of a little boy
named ian whose family had had another
family over for dinner and there were
three kids in that family and just ian
and his family and so the three kids had
picked what to watch on the tv and ian
missed his favorite tv show and when the
other family left he said to his mother
why is it better for three people to be
selfish rather than one
i just love that question
it's you know it's like it's challenging
something grown-ups would take for
granted that
more people want we're in a group and
more people want to do that
but you know it's a kind of challenge to
the economist way of thinking of like
let's maximize the satisfaction of
people's preferences it's a kind of
challenge to democracy lurking there too
it's just a question that no grown-up
would think to ask because we've so long
taken it for granted that well more
people want to do that so let's do it
that's fantastic well you're talking
about wonder and naivete um
starting with kind of uh in zen buddhism
that would call it a beginner's mind
so
how children grow up i got a teenager
okay scott
dr scott lawyer scott i don't know
dr lawrence uh jd um
i have a teenager and i can see
the mind
closing and it's very interesting
because
we live in such a world right now um
this i don't want i don't want reza to
get triggered here but we live in a in a
cancel culture world where there is a um
there is often a kind of a knee-jerk
crowd
response to when someone
is makes a mistake or is rude or
you know in some cases are out and out
revealing their racist stripes but
in some cases not and i've noticed this
with my son like if he if someone at
school like one kid set up called a girl
a [ __ ] at school and he's that's it
he's not talking to that kid anymore
that's it and i was like oh
interesting so what about forgiveness
what about the spiritual concept
of forgiveness you know or have you
spoken to him about this but it's like
no not interested he's a jerk and he
said that um
so
you know i'd love for you to to tackle
that one but but bigger than that like
how how do we encourage children as they
grow up into teens and as young adults
to continue
pondering to continue
keeping that fresh open
aw filled mind and developing these deep
thoughts so that we don't lose it
actually the second question is actually
easier than the first i'm not sure i you
know my kids are just approaching
adolescence so i haven't haven't quite
gotten to
uh some of the challenges challenges the
teenage years but um you know i do think
there is a way you know like the
matthews discovered gareth matthews
discovered that children would stop
spontaneously raising questions in
philosophy around age eight or nine it's
just around the time that they're
starting to become aware that other
people have views of them and so they're
feeling
less fearless than they once did they're
worried about getting things wrong or
seeming silly it's also like the time
they develop other sorts of social
interests so they're um they're
directing their attention to different
aspects of the world
but he also discovered if you created a
space where you encouraged it and you
showed that you valued it that kids
would join up to the conversation still
right so
um one thing i found in just in
conversations with my old my own kids as
they've gotten older is if it's
presented as something in in their lives
right like you know thinking about your
teenager hey why won't you talk to that
kid anymore do you believe in
forgiveness they're pretty closed down
and defensive but if it's presented as a
question about somebody else like hey
will smith did this thing right
what do you think he needs to do to
you know to make it up to
chris rock they're much more willing to
um to engage those questions
so that's one strategy is make it about
something else or somebody else but i
think i think that's really really
actually super helpful i never really
thought about that before
and if you talk about will smith and
chris rock
in the in terms of of forgiveness and by
the way listeners
scott dr professor
j j
d scott hershevitz
from of michigan and oxford
wrote a beautiful op-ed
um
about taylor swift and forgiveness that
is uh you could google that [ __ ] it's
it's pretty great but um you talk about
uh will smith and chris rock and then
uh that's that's that's great get into
the nature of forgiveness itself will
that ever be forgivable should he never
speak to him again
um does will smith owe chris rockin a
personal apology first
in order
to then
have that discussion and what's the role
of what's the role of third parties here
right so like that's the question that
your teenager is wrestling with because
he wasn't called a [ __ ] somebody else
was called a [ __ ] and he's trying to
figure out like what what am i supposed
to do and the same kind of question
becomes like you know well i i don't
know maybe i think will smith did
apologize to to chris rock so
what's what's the standing of the rest
of us relative to
will smith if chris rock makes amends do
we still get to be mad all these i think
are really interesting philosophical
questions that are just like pervasive
in our interpersonal relationships and
one thing i have fun doing in philosophy
you mentioned the taylor swift essay
is
instead of writing about this these
issues in the abstract way that lots of
academic philosophers often do can i
find the story whether it's about my
kids or taylor swift or will smith that
makes the issue come alive and people
want to debate it and then you know
halfway through the conversation i get
to say oh let me tell you what you know
some academic philosophers had to say
about this and see if it moves the
conversation forward
warby parker is committed to providing
exceptional vision care online and in
stores offering eyeglasses sunglasses
eye exams and contact lenses
glasses start at 95 dollars including
prescription lenses warby parker also
offers their very own daily contact lens
scout
by warby parker scout is a comfortable
breathable and affordably daily contact
lens
a 90 day pack is only 55 bucks
warby parker styles range from extra
narrow to extra wide to fit all face
shapes
sunglasses start at 95 dollars and are
available with prescription
just like eyeglasses their sunglasses
are available through the home try on
program
warby parker sunglasses feature premium
polarized lenses that are scratch
resistant and provide a hundred percent
uv protection
you need to try warby parker's free home
try on program order five pairs of
glasses to try on at home for free for
five days no obligation to buy ships
free includes a prepaid return shipping
label i did this it's so easy to use i
mean it's a beautiful website you've got
all the glasses there click click click
click all of a sudden couple days later
these beautiful eyeglasses are in a case
at your home try them on i like this one
i don't like this one ship them back
easy peasy pudding and pie so try your
five pairs of glasses at home
for free
at warbyparker.com
milkshake that's warbyparker.com
milkshake
trade coffee has so many different
roasts and roasters
and locations there's so many different
flavors to the beans
it makes drinking coffee such a fun
experience
to try all of these different
roasters and brands
and it's all as simple as taking a quiz
trade coffee sends you freshly roasted
beans from 60 of the country's best
craft roasters small businesses who pay
farmers fair prices to sustainably
source the greatest beans from around
the world whether your friends call you
a coffee snob
or you just know it when coffee tastes
really perfect
trades real coffee experts personally
test over 450 roasts so they know
exactly what to recommend for you
because the truth is what i like and
what you like could be totally different
you will like a selection of specific
coffees that are different from anyone
else's taste just answer a couple of
questions and you'll get your own
personalized variety of coffees
delivered fresh to you as often as you
like no gimmicks
trade delivers a bag of freshly roasted
coffee as whole beans or ground for
however you brew that at home and they
guarantee you'll love your first order
or they'll replace it for free trade has
delivered over five million bags of
fresh coffee with more than
750 000 positive reviews so right now
trade is offering new subscribers a
total of thirty dollars off your first
order plus free shipping when you go to
drinktrade.com milkshake
that's more than 40 cups of coffee for
free get started by taking their quiz at
drinktrade.com
milkshake and let trade find you a
coffee you'll love that's drinktrade.com
milkshake for 30 off
i have a another question that i want to
ask you but i thought that before we did
that it'd be fun
if we actually uh you know heard from
some kids who have some philosophical
questions we did a little kind of shout
out to uh
so this world of social media and asked
if there were kids out there who
uh are a on instagram and b
have some kind of question that they
want to ask so
we we have a few of these why don't we
listen to them and then and then you uh
maybe you know put on your philosopher's
hat and uh
and you know not so much answer the
question but tell us a little bit about
what the question reveals about yeah
let's go the brilliant uh child of
philosophy mind uh all right libor
hi my name is asa and
i'm in first grade and my question is
would you rather die by being too cold
or being too hot
oh wow
would i rather die
would you rather be getting too cold or
too too hot
can i give my answer yeah go ahead yeah
i know that's not what this is about but
i have an answer for this yeah
you have to asa you've got to
investigate the science around this
because
you 100 do not want to die by
overheating it's the worst
your blood boils and your brain expands
and freezing to death is is absolutely
the way to go if you're gonna die i hear
that too yeah you just it you feel you
actually feel warm you feel safe and
cozy and your body just starts to sleep
i'm getting sleepy
and then you just pass away it's
fantastic
absolutely so i
agree completely but i think i uh you
know just take us back to the neil
degrasse tyson conversation
there's a there's an empirical component
of this question and then a
philosophical component
exactly so we do want to know how the
science works somebody needs to tell us
what it's going to be like to die to die
in each way let's get neil degrasse
tyson on the horn
yeah but then the question once you know
which of these is a better death that's
a philosophical question the larger
philosophical question is how do you
want to die
um physically but also
kind of metaphorically yeah or also also
should death
should should you ex you know should
death be an experience right should it i
mean like the end of life like do you
want your brain to expand and explode or
do you want to just kind of drift off
into nothingness you know there's
there's some philosophy there would you
rather have a couple weeks or a couple
months knowing you're going to die to be
able to say goodbye to people would you
rather
just accidentally have your head chopped
off when someone throws a chainsaw
across the room which happens in la all
the time by the way yes i i think i
actually think about that differently
now that i have kids now that i have
kids i'd want to get some things
arranged and make sure i'm just charging
my responsibilities where before i had
responsibilities to other people
not knowing it was coming seemed like
the way to go all right let's do another
one
hi
my name is jasper and i'm 10 years old
and in fourth grade
my question is
how do we know if god is real and if
he's not who created this universe
[Music]
well that sounded like the answer to me
did i feel excited yeah
yeah yeah answer contained in the
question so
the um there's two components that
question how do you know whether god is
real and then if there is no god how did
the universe get here and um
uh i've had really phenomenal
conversations with my kids about both of
these questions and i explained in the
last chapter in the book when he was
four my older son rex just kind of
reframed my understanding of my
relationship to religion
he asked me one night is god real i was
cooking dinner and i said what do you
think and he said i think that for real
god is pretend and for pretend god is
real
i just kind of that is deep froze i was
like that sounds pretty it's like what
do you mean what do you mean and he said
well god isn't real but when we pretend
he is
and sort of reflecting on that moment
with him help me really understand my
relationship with religion because i
don't think of myself as
believing in the standard sense that i
think the stories that i'm being told
are true and they reflect to kind of the
metaphysics of the world but
nevertheless i observe lots of religious
rituals i go to synagogue i participate
in holidays i fast on yom kippur and
i've always been sort of puzzled about
this disconnect between my lack of
belief but the importance of these
religious rituals in my life
and then i realized actually like rex is
offering me a way of understanding this
that in the same way that pretending can
enrich a child's life and make their
their games their days more meaningful i
think that these religious rituals are
also enriching
my life in just the same way they
provide a framework for celebrating
things and for gathering in community
that's why they're important to me and
i'm happy to pretend even though i don't
share the metaphysical view so
um this is a little bit not not a direct
answer to how do we know whether god is
is real
but um it's an argument that maybe
religious like participation religion
doesn't require the view
that god is that god is real um
i'm skeptical that god is
uh and in part just to connect it up to
the second half of the question because
a lot of people think that god is gonna
provide explanations
why is the world here well god created
it but actually the guardian the
newspaper in london just they just did
the same thing you did for me they
gathered philosophical questions from
kids and there was a girl named leia who
said if god created the world who
created god
i think leia's got a really great
question
and uh and as i say in nasty british and
short if if god exists it's not so much
solving the mystery is to move it's like
moving a mystery elsewhere well then i
need to know why god and of course
religious folks have answers to these
questions
um but but i don't but but i find when i
think about it
god isn't actually getting me the
answers i want and that's part of what
makes me skeptical
you know it's interesting just going
along that and we're not going to make
this an episode about god but there is a
wonderful philosophical question about
god that i've heard posed a couple of
times which is that
in most beliefs about a higher power
this
creative force or presence in the
universe is is above
his quote unquote his to genderfy it
uh his creation completely above his
creation right beyond time and space etc
so
by saying does god exist
existence is a quality of creation you
know this sharpie that i'm holding in my
hand exists
god can't exist in the same way that
this sharpie exists because god is
beyond all uh qualities of his creation
anyways yeah i mean so actually that's
actually where the chapter on god in the
book starts which is to say
um what do we mean when we say that god
exists and it doesn't seem like it could
be exist in the same way your sharpie
does because that just means like has a
location in space and time and we're
told god stands outside
space and time and i draw some analogies
i mean i don't think that means god
doesn't exist i think like the number
six exists is an example i give um
though i once tried to persuade my
nephew that it didn't and we got into a
kind of comedy of errors when he came to
believe maybe that it didn't but the
number six exists not because it
exists in space and time right it's an
abstract entity that that exists
in a different kind of way the same is
that i think is true of like our rights
and responsibilities they don't have
locations in space and time so i don't
think it's out of the question that god
exists just because he doesn't have a
location space and time but the
challenge is to say well what do we mean
when we say that god
exists well said
roll the tape
i came home late from a long day at work
and jumped into bed with my daughters
who are about to fall asleep
one turns to me and asks do cockroaches
get married mom
i'm a cancer surgeon so after a day of
successfully fielding questions on life
and death i had no answers for her can
you help
p.s buying time i inquired as to why she
asked this question
apparently her father had killed a
cockroach during the day and she wanted
to know if it had a family to keep
now see this is actually
a much deeper question than it sounds on
the surface yeah there's a lot of layers
to this one i love it and i love that
this mom thought to ask the why are you
asking question
because what starts off just sounding
silly
right actually turns into something
profound she's worried about
like the moral quality of what her
father did and she thinks it depends in
part on whether there are creatures in
the world that care about that cockroach
right and then the way she asks it is to
say was that cockroach mary because
that's the framework she's got is like
nuclear family these are the people that
care about you and love you
um but it really is a question of
how
bad should we feel how upset should we
feel how bad a thing has happened in the
world as a result of this killing
the cockroach and um and and i don't
i don't know whether cockroaches care
about
uh
care about each other
um
uh
you know
i i i and again there's like a partly an
empirical kind of question here about
like the psychology and sociology of
cockroaches such as it is
um but i do love the set of thoughts and
actually now i'm finding myself
wondering like there's also like part of
what's worth having a conversation with
her about is should we care about the
cockroach even if cockroaches don't care
about each other i think that's the
direction i'd want to take the
conversation and if that was my daughter
you know there's another
layer i mean you you
tipped your hat to it but this is really
all about compassion because it's kind
of like well wait a minute if someone
stepped on
mommy then daddy would be all alone and
the family would be broken up and so
this girl is
having great compassion for the
cockroach and wondering to what degree
should i have
compassion for a cockroach and then
because we do that as humans right like
it's nothing for us to kill
uh germs we have antibacterial soap
right but then it goes to cockroaches
and then mice is that okay to kill a
mouse but then cats can't kill a cat
certainly can't kill a dog or a horse i
mean god forbid so like there's this
hierarchy of like where's the line of
what's okay to kill and not feel bad
about or not
and what role does our caring or not
caring play in setting that line right
so you said like we can't kill a dog or
a cat
is that because of
intrinsic qualities of dogs and cats or
is that because of the role that dogs
and cats play in our lives
you know i think that's a really hard
question actually it sort of plays into
debates about like the ethics of
of eating animals um you know like if
we're responding to the intrinsic status
of dogs it may be that say pigs also
have that same
intrinsic status or if our reluctance to
eat dogs is a response to
the role that dogs play in our
communities than maybe the arguments
don't transfer over
okay one last one
why the sky is big
the sky is big
yeah that's um
uh
why first of all that kid was an idiot
yeah he couldn't even like form a
sentence i know come on kid where's your
sky is big
duh we're really embarrassed sorry scott
i mean i just no no no no we don't want
to make it sound like the the little
kids who listen to our podcasts are all
that dumb is what we're trying to say
yes anyway oh you're you're giving him
too hard time that like he's describing
the answer he'd like why this guy is big
that's he doesn't phrase it as a
question he's just described a
description of what he's hoping
to know
and um
you know well i mean there's so many
different ways you could answer right
and part of the part of the fun i think
of parenting is actually just trying out
different ways
of answering so like you could play with
his smallness right um you know like and
and size being a kind of relative
concept point out things that like the
sky is not big relative to the sun or
even relative uh maybe
um to the earth relative to the solar
system uh so
i think it's fun to play around with the
ways in which these things are
relative um
yeah i mean maybe he's also asking for a
kind of creation story you know again
like part of the joy of engaging kids
about this is is probing to see like
what the nature of the inquiry is and
what they'll accept is responsive you
know earlier you had mentioned gareth
matthews a philosopher gareth matthews
and
he has this whole thing where he's like
listening to kids requires that you know
we have to be willing to relinquish what
he calls the automatic presumption of
adult superiority in knowledge and
experience which
as a parent of four children i will
admit is difficult to do right like your
your your sort of
your your standard response to
a child is that i know more than you do
because i'm an adult i've lived longer
i mean
as much as i hate this answer i can't
tell you how many times i have had to
say cause i said so um
you know and but we all do it but
i wonder you know having having written
this book and thought about it so much
um what do you think that we as adults
can learn from kids you know like how
how can we as adults
keep that same childlike wonder and
perspective
alive
so
you know matthews says at one point in
one of his books that
doing philosophy with kids can create
this totally different kind of
interaction that you can have with them
in almost every other context if they
ask you a question about science you're
in the position
of you know having superior knowledge or
if they ask you a question about how to
accomplish something in the world same
deal or if they're um like they're
looking often for permission like you're
in your role as authority whether it's
like authority about what they need to
do or authority about what you know but
one point matthew's made about
philosophy is if they're asking a
question
like
what happens after you die or
um you know like
what makes something unfair chances are
you don't really know the answer either
you may have some thoughts or ideas but
your uncertainty right creates the
possibility of a genuinely collaborative
conversation right so when i say to my
kid you know what do you think when he
asks whether god exists i do it in the
spirit of like i genuinely want to know
what you think i don't actually know the
answer to this so tell me how you're
thinking about it and i'll tell you how
i'm thinking about it and we'll have a
conversation together or if my kid tells
me that i'm being unfair or that
something in the world is unfair i may
ask them like do you think it's my
responsibility to fix that is it like my
job to make everything like between you
and your brother turn out fair and then
have a genuine conversation maybe
they'll think the answer is yes and
you'll give them like but but so one
answer to your question is
um engage in these kinds of
collaborative conversations do
philosophy with them don't teach them
philosophy so actually like don't go out
like that and read plato and tell them
what you've learned
just just engage in the inquiry with
them i think is something that's um
that is wonderful for the both of you so
you know what reza was really asking is
like how do we keep our minds open how
do we keep our hearts open how do we
keep that beginner's mind fresh but
you're saying
you do this by having a conversation
with children are there other ways that
we can kind of
implement
uh
what children naturally have in our
lives
yeah so if you don't have kids around or
you want to do it in spaces without kids
i think it's um you know it's partly
maybe just like disconnecting from the
world a bit and creating space in your
life for these conversations right so
like i am like anybody like scrolling
through my phone constantly but uh you
know and like my publisher keeps saying
like oh could you do more philosophy on
twitter or do philosophy on tiktok and i
think there may be ways to like raise
the questions but i also think like some
things in life just like they require
some time and some thought and some
slowness so
you know like a glass of wine and a
friend in a quiet space um
and
uh you know you can probably have a
great conversation about some of these
things that really you know occupied you
when you were little like hey why do you
why do you go to church do you believe
um
and i think that um
you know
we could make space for more of those
conversations in our lives
if we if we wanted to have them
absolutely um elevated conversations on
life's biggest questions
it's what i'm all about
scott
hirschevitz
the book is nasty brutish and short
adventures in philosophy
with my kids are your kids brutish
no well you mean so i
i i have like lived a journey with the
title of this book um you know as you
know it's like a quote from thomas
hobbes uh you know life within the state
of nature being uh solitary poor nasty
british and short and of course when i
had kids i thought oh like these
characters they can also be nasty
brutish and short definitely my kids
included i'm i'm pretty blessed though
they're they're cute and kind and
uncommonly so and i asked my little one
hank
when the like when the book was going to
press i said hey are you nasty and
brutish and he said i can be nasty but
i'm not british which i thought
was i thought was close enough so nasty
british and short well the book is a
delight uh for parents and kids uh it's
a great conversation starter with your
family you can sit around and have an
elevated metaphysical milkshake
discussion with your children using this
book almost as a textbook there should
be a study guide that goes along with it
by the way um
thank you so much for coming on the show
we're really thrilled to have you and um
you've really sparked our imaginations
thank you professor thank you
fascinating conversation scott percivitz
that was so great love those kids
questions and you know as i'm thinking
about it now i feel like i have a
question for you rain which is
why sky so big reza why sky so big i'll
answer that question
because science is so big
reza look at our size in relationship to
the milky way galaxy and the milky way
galaxy is only a grain of sand
of the galaxies that exist
in the universe
and
i think it's important
to know our size and to understand that
we fit into a scientific world we
perceive with senses we've got rods and
cones in our eyes to look up at the sky
and perceive it
physiologically we're having a sensation
of looking at this big sky we're using
our cognitive faculties to kind of
process the the nature of the size of
the universe itself but we're also
having
a personal experience you know david
chalmers would call it the question of
mind
um which is why are we having all of
these
feelings and thoughts and memories and
insights and
a kind of a personal
filmic cinematic narrative of our lives
as we are in the midst of science and
this
is a true
mystery of being alive
counterpoint
migo boom boom and potty
okay all right folks we're gonna give
away five copies of scott hirschevitz's
uh amazing book nasty brutish in short
uh you know how this works all you gotta
do is write a review for metaphysical
milkshake on apple podcasts email a
screenshot of the review to metaphysical
at cast media.com that's cast with the k
and we'll send the first five people to
do that at book but remember
no p.o box
uh on your address folks okay
it's already suspicious enough you know
that you have a p.o box but we can't
send a book to a po box and also
only
in the united states that's the new rule
now so all you racist many many uh
bulgarian listeners too bad
no book for you
and if you want more of life's big
questions you can find us on social
media at reza aslan at rainwilson and on
twitter at meadowmilk podcast and
instagram at metaphysical milkshake let
us know your life's big question we just
might explore them on a future episode
and remember to follow rate and review
metaphysical milkshake on apple podcasts
and wherever else you listen to podcasts
please also think about subscribing
to our youtube channel and you can watch
us have interviews
and have scintillating conversations
every week on the youtubes you can watch
while you're pooping
thank you for tuning in
and we'll see you next week
metaphysical milkshake is executive
produced by rayne wilson reza aslan and
colin thompson it is produced by safa
samazadeh yazd harris lane mick dimaria
hashem self and dj lubell
cast media is the production and
distribution partner original music by
jeff tang
[Music]
so
[Music]
i'm pretty sure neil degrasse tyson has
some opinions on women's vaginas but hey
that is the hell
um hey thanks for watching you guys for
more fantastic videos just like the one
that you watch please subscribe to our
youtube channel thank you